you guys are coming over to the states
we are coming over to the american
market you got what five shows planned
five big shows five shows for for the
remainder of 2022. uh the first one
being august 26th it's going to be the
rematch of adriana marias and uh
demetrius johnson so it'll be a great
fight one on prime video one mariah's
versus johnson two that'll be the 26th
of august it starts at 9 pm is the
league card and the main card is at 10
p.m eastern time and that fight is where
that fight is going to be broadcast from
singapore but airing during u.s prime
time oh gotcha so it will still be in
singapore where you guys you know do
your thing broadcast it here i guess you
could call this like our soft launch in
the us because all of 2022 we're going
to be broadcasting still from that side
of the planet we'll have shows in
singapore as well as various other
locations in asia but friendly to
american times all the all the all the
prime video shows will be during us
prime time so this one the main card
like i said starts at 10 pm lead card at
9.
[Music]